hey youtubers is charles is gonna be my
Walking Dead episode for video
we finally got a better person we find
out which has been doing since you got
grad
it was a little bit like the governor
episode from season four we found out
what he did after the season three
finale
all the arc in the episode was vastly
different it also give us some clues as
to who that was but Daryl at the end of
the episode 3
my turn around to give away start right
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
but cover spoilers if you haven't seen
the apps to get starting with top five
moments
number five Beth is Rick from season one
the episode starts
pretty much the same way episode 1 from
season one starts
she just shoot up in bed doesn't know
where she is Rick meted out at hospital
Beth not so much but it has become about
them adjusting to their new environment
recasting all about the apocalypse that
has to learn all about the world to the
hospital
based on the shuttle into it pretty much
looks like we're back in Atlanta that's
one of the biggest cities near where
they're at
stackable DT's that we would see some
although cations in new ways
this seems like what he was talking
about without going into crazy spoilers
based on the man a time to be spent
filming their like how late in the year
it looks like that is going to be there
for a while so she'll have her own
storyline apart from everyone else
number four welcome to the hospital you
give back what you take
sounds like a very simple economy
doesn't quite work out that way
bet starts meet all new people none of
them seemed particularly friendly with
the exception in Noah
to me it seems like just another version
a Woodbury just at the governor's
wearing a badge
that lady cop to seemed every bit as
greasy though
the tour is pretty fine especially that
elevator shaft which they later paid off
whenever the shimmy down it
remind me a little bit in the trash
compactor from Star Wars
with a walker diagonals floating around
at the bottom the lady cop that's in
charge her name is dawn learner
she explains what's going on don't view
this is a sentence if the payoff
what you takin like all the care that
she received she has to pay up
by doing work really is just like
another version at the prison
is funny Beth leaves one prison in falls
into another
all the places that you can land at this
is probably better than terminus though
number three bet verses officer me
creepy
so in addition to introducing her to the
grossest lollipop ever
officer ray provide the call to action
the best needs he's the hurdle that she
has to jump over before she can escape
it take her dragons to slay in the
episode which she a course does
wonderfully I was kinda hoping that
they'd pushing down the elevator shaft
though
does my only disappointment the woman
that turned into a walker the killed in
that Kisha Castle Hughes she's also
playing all parts and drinking Thrones
Season five so
uses the National being there if he was
going to get revenge on Walking Dead any
she get
on Game of Thrones is a San snake as I
thought it was nice but they let Beth
give him death by lollipop but smashing
a jar in his head
how's that for gross lollipops in terms
of challenges that they could have
presented
Beth Wed I felt like they could have
made a better choice the turning corman
into officer may creepy
nope I good and my biggest complaint
against the episode
is the in providing challenges for a
teenage girl to get over
her sexuality doesn't have to be one of
them or an attack on her sexuality
if you like best is just gonna go the
rest for life without ever having sex
all her boyfriend who died and now
everyone is just trying to rape her
you can let me know if you agree but do
you think that they need include the
rape
in the episode I feel like there are a
number of other ways that they could
have challenged her
a key could you just try to push her
down the elevator shaft number to bed
verses officer lerner
that's the lady cop in eventually we
learned she is every bit as ninety
is every bit on that we've seen on the
show even though officer make rapey
was the obvious fill-in she's the big
bad because she is
flat out ninety Beth knew what officer
rape wanted
rate and lollipops it's really hard to
predict crazy people's behavior though
she's gonna have to learn how to deal
with Lerner the doctor tries to justify
things by saying
as bad as it is up here it's better than
down there I'm sure the Kisha Castle
Hughes
would not agree with that she actually
wanted to die they had to force her to
let them cut her arm of
the way they let things between Beth and
learners Olympic US two
there is going to be butting heads until
bed gets out basically in credit thing
with Carol it seems like that's not
going to be for a while
like you going to change your plan
elected teased her plant was basically
just
stab everyone at the end starting with
doctor eugene who
essentially we learn is basically the
Eugene up the hospital
and my number one WTF moment bed helps
no escape
this is really the moment I bet
self-actualization she takes one for the
teams that know it can escape
and she takes down a walker hardcore in
the process business call back to
learners comments that
out there you're nothing your somebody's
burden that cost posted on at all
and helps her friend escape that's why I
think the he's the person
whose with Darrell in the bushes I think
whenever dear what that would divert
next episode he appears and it's gonna
be no behind him
he Carol want to look for bed kill shit
up in hospital at the end
that means the Terra was nearby during
their escape attend so no is pry can
explain what's going on with better
hopefully he will
that's we find are midseason finale
battle I think that the survivors
reckons survivors are going to try and
get betting Carol
there have been a lot of people trying
to post potentially spoiler things about
that so
if you have any spoilery theories just
be sure to use spoiler tags in the
comments
a lot of people are theorizing that
someone might I like a main cast member
just please use but act if you want to
talk about that let me know that what
was your favorite moment in the episode
and what do you think is going to happen
with Carol now clearly beth is gonna
have to alter her escape plan
she was just gonna stab everyone to play
it by ear but now the carols their
hopefully should be able to help overall
you the absolute assault B-plus
and a lot of people are huge fans the
best character but I said that it was
really good I thought is a call to
action
without a little bit that during the day
le Paso last season
when she was just concerned to grow up a
little bit she call bullshit on dale
nah she's gone bullshit on everyone at
the hospital I think officer lerner
character she's actually played by
Christine woods
is a really nice twist on my current
governor person
clearly she's crazy in she seems to be
just plucking people at random who she
thinks can help them
of the street I think the real question
as well as Beth gonna do with Carol
I do think the carols gonna wake up I
don't think he's going to be in a comer
ni think
officer McGrady is gone but that doesn't
mean there are other awful people
working for learner
so I don't think that counts is going to
be able to pistol at the mall there is a
theory
the Carroll intentionally allowed
herself to be found by the group
I don't think that we're going to learn
about that till we see darryl again in
an episode
hopefully he'll explain what's going on
visually their london is call backs the
previous episodes like the first episode
with Rick waking up in a hospital bed
the first episode in Season 3 with a cut
Herschel's Lake op
when they were lowering down in the
elevator shaft was also a little bit
like Glenn getting Lord in the well
during season 2
I like the way they're able to
automatically call back to previous
episodes but do it in really interesting
ways
the big thing as what are the
consequences gonna be for bed
they're definitely going to make her pay
for killing corman and for helping no
escape
I think that Carroll writing more
corrupt just a little bit so I do think
she'll have her wits about Hurd's little
bit better
should be a little bit more crossbow
Beth versus Herschel's bar/bat
also like that she realizes the doctors
a total coward
as is one more person that doesn't have
any power over her anymore and I called
him the Eugene but he might end up
turning into a bar type character
you know someone with a really weak
constitution who become someone much
stronger
or he could just take a trip down the
elevator shaft on all great episode
love the new location kiwi to see how
things develop in hospitals missing
other carols their
next week is going to be DC episode
it'll be all abraham's group so be sure
to subscribe to get my video
I'm also posting a CUNY for this
tomorrow let me know if you agree though
do you think the hospital is going to be
a battle for the midseason finale do you
feel like the survivors gonna go
and it's going to be like the next big
conflict in the meantime
you can click here mike in a video of
the incisions are posted
in you can click here from episode 3
video thank you so much for watching
total iPad LCS tomorrow